oh
[Musique]
ils sont agriculteurs dans l'orne est
fier des produits qu'ils transforment
boulangers fromagers maraîchers 28
portraits croqués par patrice olivier au
gré des saisons et j'ai tout faux
grand-angle à dire quand on rentre dans
la seine
on a des gens qui sont identifiés qui ne
sont pas anonymes et on est vraiment
dans la seine et envoie sur des photos
quoi les gens on voit leur expression on
voit leurs gestes et c'est vraiment le
là comment le parti pris en fait que
j'ai choisi pour construire cette expo
habitants fils d'agriculteur patrice est
allé à leur rencontre pour immortaliser
ces hommes et ces femmes qui font vivre
leur territoire des photos en circuit
court que nous avions capté l'automne
dernier une lettre à mme kjaersgaard
temps en temps pas tout le temps parce
qu'il faut bien la façon dont il fait du
noir et blanc ça met vraiment en valeur
le ca fait des belles photos ça c'est
une manière d'immortaliser un peu le
travail qu'on fait je pense va très bien
génial moi je mets en avant c'est le
producteur dans le cadre de son activité
clé la perte intrus se défend la petite
personne au travers de son activité
parce que là on n'est pas dans une
activité industrielle c'est des gens
pour beaucoup d'entre eux qui défendent
une équipe de production et qui aiment
ce qu'ils font et surtout qui défend la
notion de qualité un travail presque
sociologique sur des professionnels qui
selon patrice recréer ce lien de
confiance entre l'agriculteur et
population urbaine
tous ont été fiers d'être captée par
l'oeil du photographe et la magie a
parfois au péril et madame bidart dans
cette salle de traite donc je la prends
en train de m comment les griffes sur
les manettes des vaches et et elle me
regarda ce moment là et il ya quelque
chose qui se passe dans son regard d'un
petit moment magique dure pas longtemps
qui fait pas on en accord quoi sert de
ce qu'on veut faire et moi ce que je
veux faire et ça c'est cette côte et au
sein pas du travail un travail sous
forme de livre et d'expos visible
conseil départemental de l'ordre
jusqu'au 2 septembre